Pierre is 10, and he practices in matches of the Stateway Park Gladiators, his community boxing team. At the end of a fight, if Pierre needs that extra boost, he has a special technique. He says he got it thinking about the cartoon, The Incredible Hulk.
皮埃尔今年10岁，他会在社区拳击队“Stateway Park Gladiators”的比赛中训练。在一场比赛结束时，如果皮埃尔需要额外的动力，他有一种特殊的技术。他说这个灵感来自于动画片《绿巨人》。
Because I was thinking about the Hulk when [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. So Incredible Hulk, throw you down and stuff. He go wild and stuff.
因为我在想绿巨人的时候[听不清楚]。所以不可思议的绿巨人，把你摔倒之类的。他会变得狂野之类的。
When he spars, here's what happens. His buddies on the team, led by Coach Frank Smith, start chanting.
当他进行实战训练时，事情是这样的。由弗兰克·史密斯教练带领的队友们开始齐声呐喊。
Hulk time, baby.
绿巨人时间到了，宝贝。
He's getting mad. Uh oh. Hulk time, baby.
他快气疯了。噢，不。绿巨人时间到了，宝贝。
And then Pierre, in the middle of the ring, starts to shake. His whole body vibrates. His head lowers. His eyes get glassy. He transforms from a loser into somebody who dominates with punches, with a crazy flurry of hitting.
然后，皮埃尔在拳击台中央开始颤抖。他的全身都在振动。他低下头。他的眼神变得呆滞。他从一个失败者变成了一个用拳头统治全场、打出一连串疯狂攻击的人。
I started hitting him so hard when I get mad, thinking I was going to lose. And I turn to Hulk.
当我生气的时候，想到我要输了，我就开始重重地打他。我就变成了绿巨人。
I look all wild, silly. When I get to punching, there ain't going to be no taps. It's going to be hard, like real fighting people. And they winning belts and stuff.
我看起来很狂野、很傻。当我开始出拳时，绝对不会是轻轻地拍打。那会是很重的拳头，就像真正打架的人一样。他们还赢得了金腰带之类的东西。
A guy named Max Kellerman, who does this public access TV show called, Max on Boxing, told me this story. He said that in Muhammad Ali's biography, Ali said that when he was hit really hard in the ring, he would enter this room in his mind. A room he says that all boxers enter when they're beaten hard enough. And on the wall of the room were these masks. And at some point, Ali had a fight where he took a real pounding and he entered the room and he looked around at the masks and he realized that he could put one of the masks on. So he did and he says that's how he was able to last the round.
一个名叫马克斯·凯勒曼的人，他主持一个名为《马克斯谈拳击》的公共电视节目，他给我讲了这个故事。他说在穆罕默德·阿里传记中，阿里提到当他在拳击台上遭到重击时，他会进入自己脑海中的一个房间。他说这是所有拳击手在被打得很惨时都会进入的房间。房间的墙上挂着面具。有一次，阿里在一场比赛中遭到痛打，他进入了那个房间，环顾那些面具，意识到他可以戴上其中一个。于是他照做了，他说这就是他能够坚持完那个回合的原因。
Hulk time.
绿巨人时间。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
It's the most natural thing in the world to punch someone in the face. And it's also the most unnatural. You have to psych up. You have to transform yourself. You have to do something to become the person who could put himself or herself straight into danger and throw the punch. And then, once you become that person, once you become that, then who are you? From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass.
打别人的脸是世界上最自然的事情。同时也是最不自然的事情。你必须做好心理准备。你必须改变自己。你必须做点什么，让自己成为那个敢于直面危险并挥出拳头的人。然后，一旦你成了那个人，一旦你成了那样，那你又是谁呢？来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our program, Throwing the First Punch. And who you become when you're able to throw the first punch. And how hard it is to stop being the person who throws the first punch. Round One, I Would Probably Slug Jesus, A nice guy from Brooklyn explains why he loved to fight in bars and how hard it is to stop.
今天我们的节目主题是“挥出第一拳”。以及当你能够挥出第一拳时，你会变成什么样的人。还有停止做那个挥出第一拳的人有多么困难。第一回合，“我可能会揍耶稣”，一个来自布鲁克林的友善小伙解释了他为什么喜欢在酒吧打架，以及停止这种行为有多难。
Round Two, To Boldly Go Where No Woman Has Gone Before, the story of someone who finds the thing that means more to her than anything in the world is boxing and why she has to give it up.
第二回合，“大胆前往女性未曾涉足之地”，讲述了一个发现拳击对她来说比世上任何东西都重要，以及她为何必须放弃它的故事。
Round Three, Fighting Is Work, A man who, at 2:30 in the morning in a club in Chicago, takes on all comers, and beats them, and well and why for him it's just a job. Stay with us.
第三回合，“打架就是工作”，一个男人在凌晨两点半的芝加哥俱乐部里，接受所有挑战者，并击败他们，以及为什么对他来说这只是一份工作。请继续收听。
Round One. Manny Howard grew up in Brooklyn in a working class Irish enclave. He learned to fight with the other kids there. And he loved fighting, saw himself as a bully. He was such a committed fighter that when he got older he became the first person to get suspended from Vassar College for fighting. And now he's trying to stop. He's trying to stop being the one who always throws a punch. But moving from that world into the world that most of us inhabit isn't easy. He spoke with Paul Tough.
第一回合。曼尼·霍华德在布鲁克林的一个工人阶级爱尔兰飞地长大。他在那里学会了和其他孩子打架。他热爱打架，自视为一个恶霸。他是一个如此执着的打架者，以至于长大后成了瓦萨学院第一个因打架而被停学的人。现在他正试图停止。他试图不再做那个总是挥拳打人的人。但从那个世界进入我们大多数人居住的世界并不容易。他和保罗·塔夫进行了交谈。
Heidi takes a cab ride home every night, which is $8.50. And we took this ride that ended up being $11.00. Clearly the meter was fast and I said to the guy, give me the receipt. I'm not going to pay for the ride. And he said, oh, I knew the meter was fast. I meant to get that fixed.
海蒂每天乘出租车回家，车费是8.50美元。我们坐的那次车费最后变成了11美元。很明显计价器跳得太快了，我对司机说，给我收据。我不会付这笔车费。他说，哦，我知道计价器跳得快。我打算去修一下。
One thing led to another and I basically snapped and grabbed him and folded him up. He was outside of the cab and I was outside of the cab and I threw him inside the cab and slammed the door on his legs and he drove away.
事情一件接一件，我基本上情绪失控了，抓住他并把他折叠起来。他当时在车外，我也在车外，我把他扔进车里，把车门重重地关在他的腿上，他就开车走了。
So was it like a standoff sort of thing where the two of you were standing outside the cab sort of shoving each other?
所以这就像是一种对峙，你们两个站在车外互相推搡？
Yeah, you pay me. You pay me. No, I won't pay you. You pay me no. No, I won't pay you. And then he said that I was an enemy of the people. Which, since he was ripping me off, seemed like a pretty outrageous claim. But I snapped, and I just charged him. That's a failing on my part. I should be able to take his number and complain to the Taxi and Limousine Commission and take him to court, do it the right way. There's always a way out of a fight.
对，你付钱给我。你付钱给我。不，我不付钱。你付钱给我，不。不，我不付钱。然后他说我是人民的敌人。鉴于他在敲诈我，这听起来是个相当离谱的说法。但我发火了，就冲向了他。那是我的错。我本应该记下他的车号，向出租车和豪华轿车委员会投诉，并把他告上法庭，用正确的方式处理。打架总是有退路的。
You were with your wife and you were with another guy. And how did the two of them react?
当时你和你的妻子在一起，还有另外一个人。他们两个是怎么反应的？
Sam loved it, and Heidi hated it. Heidi walked away.
萨姆很喜欢，海蒂很讨厌。海蒂走开了。
Did she give you a hard time?
她有没有让你难堪？
Oh, yeah. I had to sleep out of the house. I had to go around the corner, sleep at my mom's house. Arguably, a fair punishment.
哦，当然。我不得不睡在屋外。我不得不绕过街角，睡在我妈家。可以说，这是公平的惩罚。
I remember being a little kid and running away from a fight and being terrified and being blind and running and running and running and running. And it occurred to me that if people-- it's like playground fighting, but it's pretty traumatic when you're a little kid. Somebody chasing you around threatening to beat you over the head and you're just terrified about what-- you're not sure exactly what it is except that somebody said they're going to beat you over the head. So you run and  you run and you run and you hope that you never get caught. And then, if you do get caught, you get a beating on the head. It's more humiliating than it is hurtful. But at some point you decide, well, I'm not going to be the guy being chased in the playground. I'm going to do the chasing. It's as much to avoid the humiliation of having to run away as it is really enjoying doling it out. Although you quickly learn to enjoy being a bully.
我记得小时候逃避打架，被吓坏了，眼前发黑，拼命地跑啊跑。我当时想，如果是人们——这就像操场上的打架，但当你是个小孩子时，这非常痛苦。有人追着你威胁要打破你的头，你吓坏了，不知道究竟会发生什么，只知道有人说要打破你的头。所以你不停地跑，希望永远不要被抓住。如果你真的被抓住了，你的头就会挨打。这与其说是伤害，不如说是屈辱。但在某个时刻，你决定，好吧，我不要做操场上被追的那个人。我要做那个追人的人。这与其说是享受打人的乐趣，不如说是为了避免不得不逃跑的羞辱。虽然你很快就会学会享受做一个恶霸的乐趣。
But you're saying there was a moment where you made that decision for yourself?
但你是说有一个时刻你为自己做出了那个决定？
Yeah, I thought if you can choose to be the guy throwing the beating, then you might as well be that guy instead of the guy getting the beating.
是的，我想如果你可以选择做那个打人的人，那么你最好做那个人，而不是做那个挨打的人。
The things that I learned early on were you prepare for a fight way ahead of time. If you're going to go out at night, you wear big shoes because you end up on the floor getting dragged around and sometimes you have to kick people. Always throw the first punch. Punch in the throat and the eyes, the nuts, and the knees. Don't bother with any other part of the body if you want to win the fight. Never tell anybody you're going to fight them. Just punch them.
我早年学到的东西是，你要提前做好打架准备。如果你晚上要出门，穿大鞋子，因为你最终可能会倒在地板上被拖来拖去，有时你不得不踢人。一定要先出手。打喉咙、眼睛、要害和膝盖。如果你想打赢，就别管身体的其他部位。永远不要告诉任何人你要打他们。直接打。
It's important to be the guy who can throw the punch to me. And it's more important than whether or not you win the fights or not, I think. But it's a hard thing to do, to throw a punch. Because you don't know what's going to happen afterwards. Then you get your ass kicked, and it's happened a lot. You throw a punch and then they come back at you 10 at a time and you lost that one.
对我来说，做一个能挥拳打人的人很重要。我认为这比你是否赢得比赛更重要。但这很难，挥出那一拳。因为你不知道接下来会发生什么。然后你会被打得屁滚尿流，这种情况发生过很多次。你挥出一拳，然后他们十个人一起冲上来，你就输了那一场。
Before I got into fights, or before I had my first fight and was mostly running away from fights, everything seemed to happen really, really quickly. Never was clear in your memory what had happened and why you were running down the street or the panic. But after the first fight, I realized that if you actually get in a fight, everything slows down. I suppose it's adrenaline. You have time to think about everything. It's like being in a car crash. You notice things-- what people are looking at, what the person you're about to fight with is looking at, what he's paying attention to, where his hands are, if he's the kind of guy who's going to hit you first, all that stuff. You have this heightened awareness. It doesn't hurt then, but it's scary. But nothing hurts really.
在我开始打架之前，或者在我第一次打架之前，那时我大多是在逃跑，一切似乎发生得非常非常快。记忆中从不清楚发生了什么，也不知道你为什么在街上跑或者为什么惊慌失措。但在第一次打架后，我意识到如果你真的参与打架，一切都会慢下来。我想这是肾上腺素的作用。你有时间思考一切。这就像遭遇车祸。你注意到了很多事情——人们在看什么，你要与之打架的人在看什么，他在关注什么，他的手在哪里，他是否是那种会先打你的人，诸如此类。你有一种高度的警觉。那时不疼，但很吓人。其实什么都不疼。
Really? So when you're in a fight there's no pain at all?
真的吗？所以当你打架时一点都不疼？
I mean, I'm sure that there is, but it's not unbearable pain. You don't give up because of the pain. And I don't think I've ever been beaten bad enough so that you would-- I've never been beaten with a bat so that things break and start working. But being punched doesn't really hurt. It's just exhausting. That's why fights don't last very long. It's too exhausting.
我是说，我肯定是有痛感的，但不是无法忍受的痛苦。你不会因为疼痛而放弃。我不认为我曾经被打得那么惨，以至于……我从未被棍棒打到骨折或失去功能。但被拳头击中并不会真正疼痛。只是精疲力竭。这就是为什么打架持续时间不会太长。太累了。
It's exhausting to punch something, or it's exhausting to get punched by somebody?
挥拳打人很累，还是被人打很累？
Both.
都累。
How is that exhausting?
怎么会累呢？
It takes a lot of energy to punch somebody, and it hurts a lot when you do it. I know that you're never more tired than after you've gotten a good beating or you've given one. And it doesn't seem to be any more tiring getting beaten than beating up somebody.
挥拳打人需要很多能量，而且打人时手也会很痛。我知道当你被痛打或者你痛打别人之后，你会非常疲惫。而且被别人打似乎并不比打别人更累人。
We were at some college bar and somebody came running over all dramatic and flushed and said Evan was in the hospital and had his teeth knocked out by the rugby team. So we all got in this car and drove to the hospital-- I think it was St. Francis Hospital in Poughkeepsie-- and stormed the emergency room through the double doors, screaming Evan's name, looking for Evan, feeling very excitable. And Evan appeared from behind the screen. I'll never forget his face. His front two teeth were just gone, and his lips were all swollen He had these big eye like, big, puppy dog eyes. And he's speaking with a lisp, talking to us. And very dramatically somebody-- it was probably me-- said, what do you want to do? Do you want to go get them, or do you want to call college court in the morning and press charges? Because we can't do both.
我们当时在某个大学酒吧，有人气喘吁吁地跑过来，神色紧张地说埃文在医院，牙齿被橄榄球队的人打掉了。所以我们都上了车，开车去了医院——我想是波基普西的圣弗朗西斯医院——闯进急诊室的双开门，大喊埃文的名字，寻找埃文，感觉非常激动。埃文从屏幕后面出现了。我永远不会忘记他的脸。他前面的两颗门牙没了，嘴唇肿得厉害。他那双大眼睛看起来像小狗一样。他说话含糊不清。很戏剧性地，有人——可能是我——说，你想怎么办？你是想去报复他们，还是明天去学校法庭起诉？因为我们不能两者都做。
It was kind of a little bit of a movie moment?
那有点像电影里的时刻吗？
Oh, God. It's hideous, yeah. And so Evan of course said, with his big lips said, let's get them.
哦，天哪。那真是太丑陋了。所以埃文当然嘟囔着大嘴唇说，去报复他们。
About eight of us went to a bar off campus where we knew the rugby team would be. And we called them out to have a fight.
我们大约八个人去了校外的一家酒吧，知道橄榄球队的人会在那里。我们叫他们出来打架。
What do you mean? How'd you do that?
什么意思？你怎么做到的？
We opened the door and started screaming at them to come out and fight. We'd been drinking for the most part of the evening, so I don't remember exactly what it was that was said. Anyway, 11 guys piled out of the bar with about five rugby girls, the women who hung around with the rugby team. And Evan started insulting the women, which just incited everybody. Including actually, the rugby coach was there as well. A guy named Dennis. And at some point Dennis got upset because Evan was insulting his girlfriend and rushed Evan. And Evan ran away. And poor Evan had had his teeth knocked out already. But that wasn't good for morale for the troops. Because everybody but me and the two other guys named John left.
我们推开门，开始冲他们尖叫，让他们出来打架。那天晚上我们喝了不少，所以我记不清具体说了什么。总之，11个家伙从酒吧里冲了出来，还有大约五个橄榄球队的女生，那些经常和橄榄球队混在一起的女人。埃文开始侮辱那些女人，这激怒了所有人。包括橄榄球队教练也在这里，一个叫丹尼斯的家伙。在某个时刻，丹尼斯因为埃文侮辱他的女朋友而感到生气，冲向埃文。埃文跑了。可怜的埃文牙齿已经被打掉了。但这对抗击士气不利。因为除了我和另外两个叫约翰的家伙之外，所有人都走了。
And the fight had already progressed to a point where we were in a circle of guys and it was about to happen. So there was no real going back. And I'll never forget watching John-- the bigger of the two Johns-- grab a guy named Andy by the balls and by the throat and lift him up over his shoulders and over a bush, where he just disappeared. There were no more Andy. And then he clapped his hands, cleaned his hands, and walked away across the street to find somebody else to punch.
打斗已经进行到我们被包围的程度，事情一触即发。所以已经没有退路了。我永远不会忘记看到约翰——两个约翰中体型较大的那个——抓住一个叫安迪的家伙的睾丸和喉咙，把他举过肩膀，扔过灌木丛，他就消失了。再也没有安迪了。然后他拍了拍手，擦干净手，径直穿过马路去寻找其他人来打。
Now I remember seeing that while I was getting the back of my head and the front of my head pounded at the same time by two other guys. Every time I turned around to face somebody to fight them, the guy behind me would punch me in the back of the head. And I remember thinking, this is how people die in fights. This is what happens. You get hit so hard that your neck breaks.
现在我记得当我看到那一幕时，我的后脑勺和前额正同时被另外两个人猛击。每次我转身面对一个人打架时，身后的人就会重击我的后脑勺。我记得当时想，这就是人们在打架中死亡的方式。这就是会发生的事。你被打得太重，以至于颈部断裂。
And then I heard this inhuman scream. And I looked on the floor, and there was the other John, the smaller of the two Johns. And the rugby coach had three fingers of John's hand is his mouth. And there was blood rimming from his mouth. He was chewing on John's fingers. And John couldn't move, and his hands were being chewed on. I was so freaked out by that. I walked over and I kicked the coach in his head as hard as I could. And his jaw sprung open, and he sort of looked around. And he got up. And so it was me and the coach facing each other. And he just started walking towards me. And I started walking backwards. And he just kept coming. And I thought, well, I can walk all the way home. He's just going to follow me, so I better just stop. And then I stopped and as he came towards me, I set my foot and took that step forward and I punched him as hard as I could in the face. Harder than I've ever punched anybody in my life. And he fell over.
然后我听到一声非人的尖叫。我看向地面，是另一个约翰，两个约翰中较小的那个。橄榄球队教练正把约翰的三个手指塞进嘴里。他的嘴里渗出血。他在咀嚼约翰的手指。约翰无法动弹，他的手正在被咀嚼。我被吓坏了。我走过去，用尽全力踢了教练的头。他的下巴张开了，他有些迷茫地环顾四周。他站了起来。现在是我和教练面对面。他开始朝我走来。我开始向后退。他不停地逼近。我想，好吧，我可以一直退到家。他会一直跟着我的，所以我最好停下来。然后我停下了，当他朝我走来时，我站稳脚跟，向前迈了一步，用尽全力往他脸上打了一拳。比我这辈子打过的任何人都要用力。他倒下了。
And first of all, it hurt like hell. My hand hurt. And I thought, wow, I knocked out the coach. But he popped up, like one of those Bozo the Clown punching dolls. He was on the ground for a second before he was standing up again.
首先，这疼得要命。我的手很疼。我想，哇，我把教练打倒了。但他像个不倒翁一样弹了起来。他在地上待了一秒钟，又站起来了。
A second where everything was working out.
那一秒钟感觉一切都奏效了。
Time slows down. And he just kept coming. And so I turned around to run away. And I turned around and ran into a visiting alumni whose name was Bear. And he was so much bigger than me. He just got me in a bear hug, which I guess what he's named for. And he turned me on my head, and he dropped me on my face on the concrete, right on the curb. And then the coach stood on my head and started stomping my head into the road. And it's one of those suburban roads that are paved with gravel. And so I got all the skin torn off the high point on my face, above my eye and on my chin and on my jaw. And then mercifully, we all heard police sirens.
时间慢了下来。他还是不停地逼近。所以我转身想跑。我一转身，撞上了一个叫“熊”的校友。他比我大得多。他给了我一个熊抱，我想这就是他名字的由来。他把我头朝下转过来，然后把我的脸重重地摔在水泥地上，正好摔在马路牙子上。接着教练踩在我的头上，开始把我的头往路上踩。那是那种铺着碎石的郊区道路。所以我的脸部高处，眼睛上方、下巴和颌骨上的皮都被蹭掉了。然后万幸，我们都听到了警笛声。
I remember seeing Dennis the next morning after breakfast. My face was still all raw, and he had this big, black eye. I looked at his face and he looked at my face and we sort of apologized to each other in that way without saying I'm sorry. And we got along fine after that. We never had any trouble. And that's true for the rest of the team. If anything, we all never spoke about it again. But we all got along much better afterwards.
我记得第二天早餐后见到丹尼斯。我的脸依然伤痕累累，他有一个大大的黑眼圈。我看着他的脸，他看着我的脸，我们以那种无需道歉的方式互相道歉。之后我们相处得很好。我们再没遇到任何麻烦。球队其他人也一样。如果说有什么不同的话，那就是我们再也没有谈起过这件事。但之后我们相处得融洽多了。
Do you feel like there's some fights in which it's just like-- I mean if you're at a bar and you're with some people who want to fight and there's other people who want to fight, I mean that's just-- everybody wins?
你觉得有些打架就像是——我是说如果你在酒吧，和一些想打架的人在一起，还有另一些人也想打架，那是不是每个人都赢了？
Yeah, it's a win-win. We used to do that. We'd just fight with each other. John broke a chair over my head once. Over my back, not really my head when I was getting up from him throwing me on the ground. And it was fine. It was part of the fun. We decided to have a fight. He poked me, I poked him. He punched me, I punched him and then we were going. And it wasn't play fighting at all.
是啊，这是双赢。我们以前常那样。我们只是互相打。约翰有次在我起床时用椅子砸我的头。砸的是背，不是头。这很好，是乐趣的一部分。我们决定打一架。他戳我，我戳他。他打我，我打他，然后我们就开始了。这根本不是玩闹式的打架。
I would really, really, really feel bad about myself if I did any of the things that I did then, now. I suppose at some point it doesn't seem appropriate anymore to be behaving that way, to be looking for a fight. I see it differently. Besides my wife.
如果我现在做当时做的任何事情，我会对自己感觉非常、非常、非常糟糕。我想在某个时候，继续那样表现，继续寻找打架机会已经不合适了。我的看法改变了。除了我妻子之外。
So do you feel like-- I mean, you talked about this one moment on the schoolyard where you decided you were going to be the guy who punched instead of the guy who got punched. Do you feel like now you're trying to make the opposite decision, you're trying to become the guy who runs away again?
所以你觉得——你是说你在操场上有过那个时刻，你决定做那个挥拳的人，而不是被打的人。你觉得现在你是在试图做相反的决定，你是在试图做回那个逃跑的人吗？
I have the self-confidence now, I think, having been a bully, that I can do without it. I wouldn't be satisfied with that answer if I had never done it, if I had gone from running away to finding a solution to the problem. I'd always be haunted by the-- why didn't you just pound the guy into the ground, see if that doesn't solve the problem. And a lot of times it does. It's really fun sometimes. Square off against a guy in a bar and you know before the fight starts that you're just going to kick his ass. And he's a schmuck, and he's starting a fight with you. And he's starting a fight with you with his arms at his sides and he's leading with his face. You just can't wait for him to say enough for you to just pop him in the face. Have it be done with and hopefully you really humiliate him. That's fun.
我认为现在我有了自信，因为曾经是个恶霸，我可以不需要它了。如果我从未做过那个决定，如果我从逃跑直接转向找到解决问题的方法，我也许不会满足于这个答案。我总会被那个问题缠绕——你为什么不直接把那家伙打倒，看看能不能解决问题。很多时候确实可以。有时候这真的很有趣。在酒吧里和一个家伙对峙，在打架开始前你就知道你会踢他的屁股。他是个蠢货，他在挑衅你。他两手垂在身侧，把脸凑过来找打。你简直迫不及待地想等他开口，好给你理由直接往他脸上揍一拳。让事情结束，希望你能让他丢脸。那很有趣。
So even now you would still feel that way in a bar if there was a guy just being clearly the idiot? You'd take the first swing and you'd feel good about it?
所以即使是现在，如果酒吧里有个明显的白痴，你还是会那样感觉吗？你会先挥拳，并且感觉良好吗？
I don't know. Part of me would like to say yes, definitely. And part of me knows that I wouldn't do that anymore. In fact, I was thinking about this the other day. I wondered if I would turn the other cheek if something happened. I just don't think I would. I don't have the strength, the fortitude, to do that.
我不知道。我的一部分想说是的，肯定会。但我的一部分知道我不会再那样做了。事实上，我前几天还在思考这个问题。我想知道如果发生了什么事，我是否会转过另一边脸。我只是觉得我不会。我没有那个力量，没有那种坚韧去做那个。
What do you think of that line in the Bible of turning the other cheek?
你怎么看圣经里关于转过另一边脸的那句话？
I don't even know where to start with it. I don't know where to start with it. I can only understand it as a metaphor. I don't know how you apply it. I've only ever been in situations since I decided that I was going to be the guy throwing the punches, not getting them that I looked for the fight. So I'm the other end of the spectrum. One day I'll probably slug Jesus. I don't think that I've got what it takes to take a hit. I've spent so much time defining myself as a guy who never would.
我甚至不知道从哪里开始理解它。我不知道从哪里开始。我只能把它理解为一种隐喻。我不知道该如何应用它。自从我决定做一个挥拳的人而不是挨打的人以来，我所处的每一种情况都是我在寻找打架。所以我处于光谱的另一端。有一天我可能会揍耶稣。我不认为我有能力承受一记重击。我花了太长时间把自己定义为一个绝不挨打的人。
We have a neighbor who has a dog who barks all the time, and I used to get in big screaming matches with him about the dog. His behavior as a neighbor is outrageous. He's a bad neighbor. He should be punished. But I can't punish him. I'm not the one who's going to do the punishing. So I made that decision. And when I think about this particular instance, I think there was a time when I would have fed the dog steel wool or broken glass or something and then created a situation where the dog was dead and I obviously did it. And then there would be a fight and I could muster all the moral righteousness for being falsely accused of killing this dog and then beating the guy up as well. That sounds like something I would-- I love the idea of it now. But I know that I'm not going to poison the guy's dog. So we're just going to keep going around and around in this horrible circle where I frown at him when he says hi to me and I let him know that I disapprove of him.
我们有个邻居养的狗总是叫个不停，我过去经常因为狗和他在街上大吵大闹。作为邻居，他的行为非常恶劣。他是个糟糕的邻居。他应该受到惩罚。但我无法惩罚他。我不是那个去执行惩罚的人。所以我做了那个决定。每当我想到这件事，我想曾经有一段时间，我会给那狗喂钢丝绒或碎玻璃之类的东西，然后制造一个那狗死了的局面，并且明确是我干的。然后就会有一场打架，我可以振振有词地为自己被诬陷杀狗而辩解，顺便把那个家伙也打一顿。这听起来像是我现在依然喜欢的主意。但我知道我不会去毒害邻居的狗。所以我们只能在这可怕的循环中不断纠缠，当他向我打招呼时，我对他皱眉，让他知道我对他不满。
That's the problem with the world where you don't throw punches, things just go on and on.
这就是那个不打架的世界的问题，事情只会没完没了。
It's true. Exactly right. No quick resolution.
没错。完全正确。没有快速的解决方案。
Manny Howard still lives in Brooklyn where he writes a column about bars for the New York Press and does other writing. He talked to This American Life senior editor Paul Tough.
曼尼·霍华德依然住在布鲁克林，他为《纽约出版社》撰写关于酒吧的专栏，并从事其他写作。他接受了《美国生活》高级编辑保罗·塔夫的采访。
When is fighting cathartic? In Kodiak, Alaska, on the Fourth of July, in front of the American legion Hall, they used to set up a boxing ring and all day long, with hundreds of people watching, the citizens of Kodiak would fight. Third grade kids, fifth grade kids, and adults, lots of adults. They called it rough house boxing. Radio producers Nikki Silva and Davia Nelson, The Kitchen Sisters, witnessed it a few years back.
打架什么时候能宣泄情绪？在阿拉斯加州科迪亚克市的独立日，在美国军团大厅前，他们过去常设置一个拳击台，整整一天，有数百人观看，科迪亚克的市民们会进行搏斗。三年级的孩子、五年级的孩子，还有成年人，很多成年人。他们称之为“粗犷拳击”。广播制作人尼基·席尔瓦和达维亚·尼尔森，即“厨房姐妹”，几年前亲眼见证了这一切。
A lot of these were sort of grudge matches that had built up on fishing boats all season, and people can't very well on a fishing boat, duke it out, and have a successful run. So it's I'll meet ya at the Fourth of July and we'll work this out then.
很多这类比赛都是整个季节在渔船上积累下来的积怨，人们在渔船上不能很好地大打出手，否则没法干活。所以大家会说，“七月四号见，到时我们解决它”。
Do you see people fight their own employers?
你见过人们打自己的老板吗？
Yeah, a guy told us about fighting his own boss and that he'd given his boss two black eyes but that he had almost had a heart attack in the ring while giving his boss two black eyes. And he had to go to the hospital for a couple of hours after the event to kind of recover. It was ugly.
是的，有个家伙告诉我们关于打他老板的事，他把老板打成了两只熊猫眼，但他在台上挥拳时差点心脏病发作。事后他不得不去医院待了几个小时来恢复。那很糟糕。
Well, we need some more people on up here. Women preferably. Little kids.
好吧，我们需要更多人上来。最好是女性。还有小孩子。
In listening to the tape, we're hearing the emcee of the boxing event urge different couples that he knows are having marital trouble to get in the ring. Come on, Roxanne. Come on, Jack. get in the ring.
在听录音时，我们听到拳击赛的主持人催促他知道正有婚姻问题的夫妻进入拳击台。快点，罗克珊。快点，杰克。进入拳击台。
Jones, you and Roxanne get in there. Art, how about you over there?
琼斯，你和罗克珊进去。阿特，你那边怎么样？
It was kind of an all-purpose kind of a cleansing. A kind of a village cleansing. And I have always called the event Yom Kippur with Gloves. Because to me, I was raised with what Yom Kippur was.
这是一种万能的清理方式。一种村庄级别的清理。我一直称这个活动为“戴着手套的赎罪日”。因为对我来说，我是伴随着赎罪日的含义长大的。
Let me just say that Yom Kippur is the Jewish holiday of atonement.
我得说明一下，赎罪日是犹太教的忏悔节日。
Which you had to atone for your sins and you had to at least forgive. You might not forget, but you got to get over it. You got to move on. You got to work it out. You've got one day to do it. It was great too because it was sort of like the block party gone wild. Block party with silks.
你要为你的罪忏悔，而且至少要宽恕。你可能不会忘记，但你必须跨过去。你必须继续前进。你必须解决它。你有一天的时间来处理。这也很棒，因为这有点像失控的社区聚会。穿着丝绸的社区聚会。
The crowd fed it, and the crowd was like hungry for the game, for the sport. And people were all around us commentating, practically grabbing the microphone to get their two cents worth in.
人群推动着它，人群对这种游戏、这种运动非常渴望。人们在我们周围评头论足，几乎要抢过麦克风来发表他们的看法。
--difference in weight. Look like a boy against a man. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
……体重差异。看起来像是个男孩在打男人。[听不清楚的短语]
I don't even know how to say this. You know what this puts to shame is like Judge Wapner and The People's Court. That isn't what you want to see. What you want to see is this. If this were on TV, don't you think this would be just like a huge thing? Where like two people who have a grudge come before whoever the host of the show is going to be. Let's say George Foreman. And he's the referee of the match. He's the Judge Wapner of this thing. And then the two people would come before him, and they both would sign some sort of liability form before they go on. And just like The People's Court , then they would explain what their little tiff was about. And then we'd watch them duke it out.
我甚至不知道该怎么说。你知道这让什么节目蒙羞吗？就像《瓦普纳法官》和《人民法庭》。那不是你想看的。你想看的是这个。如果这在电视上播出，你不觉得这会是一件大事吗？就像两个有积怨的人出现在节目的主持人面前。比如乔治·福尔曼。他担任比赛的裁判。他是这件事里的瓦普纳法官。然后那两个人出现在他面前，两人在上去之前都会签署某种责任协议。就像《人民法庭》一样，然后他们会解释他们的争端是什么。然后我们看着他们打一架。
And it would be called The People's Ring.
那会被称为“人民的拳台”。
The People's Ring.
人民的拳台。
Seriously, when you think about this, do you think this would be a healthy thing if more people had this in their lives? Or do you think there's something kind of horrifying about it too?
说真的，当你想到这个时，你觉得如果更多人的生活中有了这个，会是一件健康的事吗？还是你觉得它也有些令人恐惧？
I do think it would be healthy if there was some-- Nikki's making--
我确实觉得如果有一些……尼基正在……
No.
不。
--worse face.
……做更难看的表情。
I know. I'd be kind of horrified.
我知道。我会觉得有点恐惧。
We might have to box it out.
我们可能得打一架来解决。
I know, we will. The Kitchen Sisters get in the ring. I don't know. I can't see it.
我知道，我们会的。“厨房姐妹”进入拳台。我不知道。我无法想象。
Look, I'm not going to start the committee to let's spread rough house boxing for the millennium throughout America. I'm not arguing for violence. I'm not defending violence. I just think you can't deny the violence inside most people.
听着，我不是要发起委员会来推广千禧年的粗犷拳击。我不是在支持暴力。我不是在为暴力辩护。我只是觉得你不能否认大多数人内心深处的暴力。
Nikki Silva and Davia Nelson. The town of Kodiak stopped rough house boxing years ago because of insurance reasons. There was no way to prevent lawsuits about split eyes and busted noses. Those insurance companies ruining our great American traditions.
尼基·席尔瓦和达维亚·尼尔森。科迪亚克镇因为保险原因几年前停止了粗犷拳击。无法避免关于眼睛破裂和鼻子打断的诉讼。那些保险公司毁了我们伟大的美国传统。
Coming up, girl meets ring, girl loves ring, girl leaves ring, sort of. And boxing as a job. That's in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，女孩遇见拳台，女孩爱上拳台，女孩离开拳台，算是吧。还有拳击作为一种工作。国际公共广播电台的节目将在片刻后继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, being the person who throws the first punch and what happens to you when you become that person and how hard it is to stop being that person. We've arrived at Act Two of our show. Round Two, To Boldly Go Where No Woman has Gone Before. We have this story of loving to fight from Meema Spadola.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，为您带来关于这个主题的各种故事。今天的节目主题是做那个挥出第一拳的人，以及当你成为那个人后会发生什么，还有停止做那个人有多难。我们已经来到了节目的第二部分。第二回合，“大胆前往女性未曾涉足之地”。我们要讲这个关于热爱打架的故事，讲述者是米玛·斯帕多拉。
Maritza was an accountant, a financial analyst at a huge insurance company. She was living day to day like anybody else. Then she heard about this boxing class that was being offered at the company gym. Some guy named Milton was teaching. Maritza liked sports. She'd even taken an aerobic boxing class before, so she decided to go down and check it out.
玛丽莎曾是一名会计师，一家大型保险公司的财务分析师。她过着和普通人一样的日常生活。然后她听说公司健身房提供拳击课。一个叫弥尔顿的人在教拳。玛丽莎喜欢运动。她以前甚至上过有氧拳击课，所以她决定去看看。
Here I am in a suit, coming in. It's the first time. I didn't have a chance to change. So I'm walking in all suited up. So he comes in, he's saying well, you know, I'm hear to teach boxing. I said, well, so? And? I wasn't impressed.
我就穿着西装进来了。那是第一次。我没机会换衣服。所以我穿着全套西装进去了。他走过来说，好吧，你知道，我是来教拳击的。我说，那又怎样？然后呢？我没留下什么印象。
So Maritza comes up and she's so short. She goes, I want to get rid of my stomach. I want to get rid of my gut. And so she was so short. I look at her. I go, honey, I teach boxing. This ain't boxing aerobics. You know, aero boxing. This is boxing. You want to learn how to box, you came to the right place. If you want to come and dance around, jump around, I says, I'm not the guy for you. So this ain't what you want.
玛丽莎走过来，她太矮了。她说，我想减掉肚子。我想减掉肚腩。她太矮了。我看着她。我说，亲爱的，我教的是拳击。这不是拳击操。你知道，那是健美操。这是拳击。你想学怎么打拳，你就来对地方了。如果你想来这里跳来跳去，蹦蹦跳跳，我说，我不是你要找的人。所以这不是你想要的。
He wasn't even thinking about me. There's another girl who thinks this is aero-- I mean-- so I threw a punch at him. Oh, you got a pretty good punch there. And he goes, let me see what you got. Bam, bam. You got a pretty good punch there, he goes. But who taught you how to box? Two steps. Then he's like trying to fix me. I'm going to teach you how to weave, but I'm going to shine you up like an old shoe and polish you up. He made me laugh. I thought he was amusing. I found it amusing. It reminded me of watching the old movies and this guy telling me I'm like an old shoe. He's going to polish me. This guy's got an act.
他根本没把我当回事。还有别的女孩以为这是健美操——我的意思是——所以我朝他挥了一拳。哦，你拳头打得不错。他说，让我看看你有什么本事。砰，砰。你的拳头相当不错，他说。但是谁教你打拳的？两步。然后他开始尝试修正我的动作。我要教你怎么闪躲，我要把你像旧鞋子一样擦亮，给你抛光。他让我笑了。我觉得他很有趣。我发现这很有趣。这让我想起看老电影，那个家伙跟我说我像只旧鞋子。他要帮我抛光。这家伙真有表演天赋。
So I started working with her every day, come down with the pads. Giving her combinations so she started falling into place. So I was like, whoa. I said, you know something? If I could bring you to my gym in Brooklyn, I says, you could win in New York City Golden Gloves. She goes, I can? I go, honey, what I got you doing right now, no girl fights the way you do right now.
所以我每天都和她练习，带着手靶。给她组合拳，她开始步入正轨。我就想，哇。我说，你知道吗？如果我能带你去布鲁克林的健身房，我说，你可以赢得纽约金手套奖。她说，我能吗？我说，亲爱的，我让你做的这些动作，现在没有女孩能打出你这样的拳。
That's how it all started.
一切就是这样开始的。
Every day after work in Manhattan, Maritza would take the subway all the way out to Brooklyn to train for three or four hours at Milton's gym and then go all the way back home to Queens. She spent her weekends at the gym. No one in her old life understood what she was doing. She'd grown up in the projects, put herself through college, gotten an MBA, held a good paying job, and here she was back so close to the streets.
在曼哈顿下班后的每一天，玛丽莎都会坐地铁一路去布鲁克林，在弥尔顿的健身房训练三四个小时，然后一路回到皇后区的家中。她把周末都花在健身房。她过去生活中的没有人理解她在做什么。她在政府保障房长大，靠自己读完大学，拿到MBA学位，拥有一份高薪工作，结果她现在又回到了离街头这么近的地方。
When she got a broken nose and black eyes in the ring, she lied to her coworkers about it, didn't tell them she was boxing. Her parents didn't approve of women fighting. They were conservative, born in Puerto Rico. Her friends were suspicious of her weight loss. They accused her of being anorexic, infected with HIV, or addicted to drugs. But at the gym, everyone believed in her. Maritza was the only girl at Milton's, his first girl, so she'd spar with the men there.
当她在拳击台上被打断鼻梁、双眼淤青时，她对同事撒谎，没告诉他们她在打拳。她的父母不支持女性打架。他们很保守，出生在波多黎各。她的朋友们怀疑她为什么变瘦了。他们指责她患有厌食症、感染了HIV，或者吸毒。但在健身房，每个人都相信她。玛丽莎是弥尔顿拳馆唯一的女孩，他的第一个女学生，所以她和那里的男人们对练。
She took Joey one day and she was throwing nonstop combinations and punches repetitiously. There was an old man sitting down in the chair and he goes, god damn that boy can throw some punches. She had the head gear on. So when she finished he came over to me. He goes, that's going to be one good damn fighter. That boy is going to be great. He goes, who is that? I go, what guy you talking about? He goes, that guy. I go, I hate to tell you this, that's no guy. He goes, what do you mean, that's no guy? Looked like a guy. I go, that's a girl. That ain't no damn girl. I go, that's a girl. He goes, get out of here. So I said, Maritza come here. So she come over to me and I took off her head gear. I go, does she look like a girl now? He goes, oh.
有一天她对练乔伊，她不断地打出连环组合拳。有个老人坐在椅子上，他说，该死，那个男孩拳头打得真不错。她戴着护头。所以当她结束时，他走到我身边。他说，那会是个顶级的拳击手。那个男孩会很棒。他说，那是谁？我说，你说哪个家伙？他说，那个家伙。我说，我不想告诉你这个，那不是个家伙。他说，什么意思，那不是家伙？看起来像个家伙。我说，那是女孩。那可不是什么该死的女孩。我说，那是女孩。他说，别开玩笑了。所以我说，玛丽莎过来。她走过来，我摘下了她的护头。我说，现在她看起来像个女孩了吗？他说，哦。
Looking at Maritza, you probably wouldn't think boxer. She's small, just over 5 feet tall and only 106 pounds. Her features are fine and delicate. But when she talks about her love for boxing, you can see her in the ring. She's radiant. It's like speaking to someone who's had a religious conversion.
看着玛丽莎，你可能不会想到拳击手。她很小，身高刚过5英尺，体重只有106磅。她的五官精致细腻。但当她谈论对拳击的热爱时，你可以看到她在拳台上的样子。她是光芒四射的。就像在和一个经历了宗教皈依的人交谈。
Boxing has shed a light on me. It's like my vision. It's like I just obtained vision. This is what I was put here for.
拳击为我打开了一盏灯。就像我的愿景。就像我刚获得了愿景一样。这就是我来到世上的使命。
Ladies and gentlemen, tonight's next bout is the women's 106 pound class. The referee is Pete Santiago. In the gold corner, Maritza Arroyo, from the Supreme Team Boxing Club. Arroyo is a financial analyst and a part-time personal trainer. She's been boxing for a year and is a Metros champ. This is her first--
女士们先生们，今晚的下一场比赛是女子106磅级。裁判是皮特·圣地亚哥。金色边角，玛丽莎·阿罗约，来自至尊拳击俱乐部。阿罗约是一位财务分析师和兼职私人教练。她练拳一年了，是都市拳击冠军。这是她的第一……
With Milton's training, Maritza was unbeatable. Within a year she had taken all the amateur titles in New York. She won the Metros, the Empire States, and in '96 she won the biggest of all, the Golden Gloves in Madison Square Garden, a fight televised around the world, held in a ring where some of the greatest boxers in history have fought.
在弥尔顿的训练下，玛丽莎是不可战胜的。一年之内，她赢得了纽约所有的业余冠军头衔。她赢得了都市冠军、帝国州冠军，并在96年赢得了最重要的一个，麦迪逊广场花园的金手套奖，那是一场向全世界直播的比赛，在历史上一些最伟大的拳击手曾经奋斗过的拳台举行。
Two straight left hands by Arroyo. And another straight left. Four straight left hands by Arroyo.
阿罗约打出两记直左拳。又是一记直左拳。阿罗约连续四记直左拳。
Maritza and I get together to watch the video of her '96 Golden Gloves win. The Garden's packed. The crowd's going wild. Martiza's incredibly fast and beautiful in the ring. Watching her, you understand what it means to be a smart fighter. She's calculated. The woman she's fighting is taller than she is, with longer arms. So Maritza ducks down low and jabs up to the body, choosing where she lands her punches-- to the ribs, then to the chest.
玛丽莎和我聚在一起观看她96年获得金手套奖的录像。花园体育馆挤满了人。人群疯狂了。玛丽莎在拳台上非常快，非常漂亮。看着她，你明白什么是聪明的打法。她是经过计算的。和她对打的女人比她高，手臂更长。所以玛丽莎压低身体，往腹部刺拳，选择她的出拳落点——肋骨，然后是胸口。
And when her opponent can barely catch her breath, Maritza's up, giving her a fierce combination to the face and head.
当对手几乎喘不过气时，玛丽莎站起来，对着她的脸和头部打出一套猛烈的组合拳。
There goes the upper cuts. There goes another one to the body.
上勾拳来了。又是一记击打腹部。
Ow.
噢。
Another one to the body. Another one. Another one.
又是一记击打腹部。又一记。又一记。
And another. Followed by a big right hook. Manson in trouble.
再一记。接着一个大右勾拳。曼森麻烦了。
In the last 10 seconds, Manson gets in a good punch, straight to Maritza's face. Maritza stumbles back and then seems to go crazy. She throws nonstop combinations, and the crowd is screaming.
最后10秒，曼森打出一记好拳，正中玛丽莎的脸。玛丽莎踉跄后退，然后似乎变得疯狂了。她打出不间断的组合拳，人群在尖叫。
There, there goes the hook. See that? That's it. 10 seconds. Bam. There you go. I threw it all. Go, go. There you go. There you go. There you go. There you go. Throw it. I missed a lot, but I threw.
那里，那个勾拳。看到了吗？就是那个。10秒。砰。就是这样。我全部打了出去。上，上。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。就是这样。打。我失手了很多次，但我挥出去了。
Can we just watch the last 10 seconds? That was so cool. Oh my God, you are so good, Maritza. I want to see you fight so badly.
我们能再看一遍最后10秒吗？那太酷了。哦，天哪，你太棒了，玛丽莎。我太想看你打拳了。
After the fight ends, we're laughing. We keep rewinding to watch Maritza's amazing finale.
比赛结束后，我们在大笑。我们不断倒带观看玛丽莎精彩的最后表演。
I'm like, really? You got it good, right? Well, OK. All right. All right. All right. All right. OK, OK. That was a grin. That was a good grin.
我当时想，真的吗？你表现得很好，对吧？好吧，好。好。好。好。OK，OK。那是个大笑。那个笑容真好。
We're both completely high and hysterical. Maritza's face is transformed. This is pure joy. And in a way, it's terrible because we both know she's quitting boxing.
我们俩都极其兴奋且歇斯底里。玛丽莎的脸变了。这是纯粹的快乐。从某种程度上说，这很可怕，因为我们都知道她要放弃拳击了。
Maritza wants to go pro, but there doesn't seem to be any way she could make a living at boxing. She's only 106 pounds. They don't even have a name for her weight class. If she went pro, no one knows of any women who are good enough to match her. As it is, there are only two amateur women at her level. In all her title matches, she's always been put up against these same two opponents over and over. And she's beat them every time.
玛丽莎想转职业，但似乎没有办法靠打拳谋生。她只有106磅。她们甚至都没有这个重量级的名称。如果她转职业，没人知道有哪个女拳手能匹配她。目前，在她这个级别只有两名业余女选手。在她所有的冠军赛中，她总是被反复安排对阵这两个对手。而她每次都打败了她们。
Maritza's lucky enough to have found the thing she loves, the thing that makes her life complete, but unlucky enough that the timing worked out all wrong. More women are getting into boxing all the time and starting younger. In 10 years, there may be enough women that Maritza would be able to make a career of it. But she's already in her 30s. She says she has to be realistic about the future. So she's gone back to school, and she's working full-time.
玛丽莎足够幸运找到了她所爱的东西，那件让她的生活变得完整的东西，但又足够不幸，时机完全不对。越来越多的女性开始投身拳击，并且从更小的年纪开始。10年后，也许会有足够的女性让玛丽莎能将其作为职业。但她已经30多岁了。她说她必须对未来现实一点。所以她重回学校，现在全职工作。
I get mixed feelings. When I go into the gym, I want to do it. But when I come away from the gym and I start looking at reality, it's like, I'm sad. It's a sadness.
我的心情很复杂。当我走进健身房，我就想打。但当我离开健身房，开始面对现实时，我就感觉很伤心。那是一种悲伤。
On the outside, no one sees it. But on the inside it's like it died. It's like, God, it could have been you. You should be in there boxing.
在外人看来，没人看得到。但在内心深处，它就像死了一样。就像，天哪，那本来可以是你的。你应该在那里打拳的。
It's like she's in love with someone she knows she has to leave. So she circles around boxing, quits, comes back for one night stands.
这就像她爱上了一个她知道必须离开的人。所以她徘徊在拳击边缘，放弃了，又回来做一次“一夜情”。
Last year, Milton signed her up for the Metros tournament without telling her. On the night of the fight, he called her from ringside and told her they were holding up the match for her. Maritza got in her car and drove from Queens to Brooklyn, while Milton lied to the judges about Maritza being stuck in traffic. She arrived, beat in her opponent in three rounds flat, but was so disgusted with herself for fighting when she was trying to retire that she left without even collecting her trophy. But being back in the game felt too good and after that win, she just couldn't bring herself to walk away. Despite her reservations, she went on to fight in the 1997 New York Gloves and, of course, won.
去年，弥尔顿没告诉她就帮她报了都市锦标赛。比赛当晚，他从拳台边给她打电话，告诉她他们为了她在拖延比赛。玛丽莎上了车，从皇后区开车去布鲁克林，同时弥尔顿向裁判撒谎说玛丽莎被困在交通里。她赶到了，三轮平打赢了对手，但因为在试图退役时还要打架而对自己感到非常恶心，以至于她没领奖杯就离开了。但回到比赛的感觉太好了，在那场胜利之后，她无法说服自己走开。尽管有所保留，她还是继续参加了1997年的纽约金手套奖，当然，赢了。
For his part, Milton had no reservations. Maritza will always be his best girl, his first girl. But he's now becoming resigned to the fact that she doesn't have much time left in boxing.
就弥尔顿而言，他毫无保留。玛丽莎永远是他最好的女孩，他的第一个女孩。但他现在已经变得无奈地接受了一个事实，那就是她在拳击界没有多少时间了。
She boxes like street people were to call [UNINTELLIGIBLE] in his prime. She's slick. She's smart. She thinks in there. She doesn't really get hit. She don't let you give her a beating. She hands out the beatings.
她的打法就像街头的人在他巅峰时期所称呼的那样。她很灵活。她很聪明。她在里面思考。她并没有真正被打到。她不让你打她。她总是率先发起进攻。
You know, I wish I would've found her when she was a little bit younger. A lot younger.
你知道，我真希望我在她更年轻一点的时候发现她。年轻得多的时候。
Here's how hard this is for Maritza. Even her plans for retirement from boxing include boxing. She's training to be a massage therapist. To massage boxers, she says. She quit her job as an accountant and now works full-time as a trainer in a gym. She has this theory that she'll get over boxing by going to boxing matches all the time.
这就是为什么这对玛丽莎来说很难。即使她从拳击退役的计划也包括拳击。她正在训练成为一名按摩治疗师。她说，去给拳击手按摩。她辞去了会计的工作，现在在一家健身房全职做教练。她有一个理论，认为通过一直去参加拳击比赛，她就能克服对拳击的瘾。
Maybe I'll overcome it by being there. Maybe that's what I need to do, is to face it. To face the fact that finally I'm not doing it anymore, that I'm not going to be boxing anymore. Maybe that's what I need.
也许我会通过在那里待着来克服它。也许这就是我需要做的，是去面对它。面对这个事实：最终我不做了，我不再打拳了。也许这就是我需要的。
Go. There it is. That's good. Come out here real quick. There you go. See the difference? Go.
开始。就是这样。那很好。出来快一点。就是这样。看到区别了吗？开始。
In February, just after Maritza misses the deadline for the 1998 Golden Gloves, I go to Milton's gym to see her fight. Even though these days Maritza isn't there much anymore, Milton has promised me that Maritza will spar with a new girl he's training. We wait and wait and no Maritza. An hour passes.
二月，就在玛丽莎错过1998年金手套奖的最后报名截止日期后，我去了弥尔顿的健身房看她打拳。尽管这些天玛丽莎不怎么去了，弥尔顿答应我玛丽莎会和他在训练的一个新女孩进行实战训练。我们等啊等，没有玛丽莎。一个小时过去了。
When she finally shows, she looks worn out and tired. She's not dressed to box, and she says she's got the flu. She's not going to fight. Right away everyone starts pushing her.
当她终于出现时，她看起来很疲惫。她没穿拳击服，她说她感冒了。她不打算打了。大家立刻开始催促她。
Well, let's just do a little.
好吧，我们就做一点点。
You want to? But I got nothing with me.
你想吗？但我什么都没带。
What do you need?
你需要什么？
Everything. I don't have nothing.
什么都要。我什么都没有。
She says she didn't bring her shoes. She doesn't have any of her gear. Milton points to some shoes lying in the corner, says they're her size. Suddenly Maritza doesn't look so tired.
她说她没带鞋。她没有任何装备。弥尔顿指着角落里的一双鞋，说是她的尺寸。突然玛丽莎看起来没那么累了。
But I got to tell you, I have no mouthpiece.
但我必须告诉你，我没带牙套。
Then Maritza drops the pretense. We head down in the elevator to her car. It turns out she's been carrying her gloves, her mouthpiece, her wraps, all of her equipment in her car for the past year just in case.
然后玛丽莎放弃了伪装。我们乘电梯下到她的车里。原来过去一年里，她一直把她的拳套、牙套、绷带，所有的装备都放在车里，以防万一。
I knew this was going to happen. That's why I don't want to come around. That's why I don't want to come.
我就知道会发生这种情况。这就是为什么我不喜欢过来。这就是为什么我不想来。
You've got the biggest smile on your face. You look so happy right now.
你的脸上挂着最大的笑容。你现在看起来太开心了。
Because I love boxing. That's why. It's what's got me where I'm at today. Very happy and very balanced I guess. We're around Second Avenue. Second Avenue. Between Second and Third and 13th Street. So here I am with no voice, going in this room to go spar. Is that crazy? That's crazy.
因为我热爱拳击。这就是为什么。是它让我成就了今天的我。我猜我很开心，很平衡。我们在第二大道附近。第二大道。在第二街和第三街以及第13街之间。所以现在我没带护具，走进这个房间去进行实战。这疯狂吗？这太疯狂了。
She grabs her bag, and we race back to the gym. And as Maritza's getting dressed, I notice she wears tiny golden gloves on a chain around her neck. Milton stands ringside, pumped up, ready to see his favorite in action again.
她抓起她的包，我们赶回健身房。当玛丽莎在穿戴时，我注意到她脖子上戴着一条项链，挂着小小的金手套。弥尔顿站在拳台边，兴奋起来，准备再次看到他最喜欢的女孩出场。
This is Howard Kelso live right here from Supreme Team Boxing.
这是霍华德·凯尔索，在至尊拳击队现场直播。
Box.
开打。
Relax your shoulders, Maritza. Relax your shoulders. Too tight. Oh, good one.
放松肩膀，玛丽莎。放松肩膀。太紧了。哦，好拳。
Maritza's stiff at first. Then she starts to relax. She's ducking down, dancing around the ring. And in the last 10 seconds of the fight, she has a surge of energy. She's punching hard, moving fast, throwing nonstop combinations.
玛丽莎起初很僵硬。然后她开始放松。她压低身体，在拳台上跳舞。在比赛的最后10秒，她能量爆发。她打得很重，移动很快，打出不间断的组合拳。
Come on, girls. Time.
加油，女孩们。时间到。
And afterwards, she's pumped up with adrenaline, sweating, laughing with Milton and the guys in the gym. She says she'll be back to spar and train every week. And even though she's missed the deadline for this year's Golden Gloves, she swears she'll take the gloves next year. Stay tuned for 1999, she says. Stay tuned.
之后，她肾上腺素飙升，出着汗，和弥尔顿以及健身房里的男人们大笑。她说她每周都会回来训练。尽管她错过了今年的金手套报名截止日期，她发誓明年一定会拿金手套。她说，请关注1999年。请关注。
But Maritza doesn't show at Milton's the next week or the week after. She breaks two appointments with me. She doesn't return my calls. And when I finally reach her, she's angry. Angry she fought again. Scared she's getting sucked back in.
但玛丽莎接下来的一周，或者再接下来的一周，都没有出现在弥尔顿的健身房。她跟我失约了两次。她没有回我的电话。当我最终找到她时，她很生气。生自己的气，因为她又打拳了。害怕自己再次被卷进去。
And how about the fact that you're still carrying around your gear?
那，你还在到处带着你的装备这件事怎么说？
Well, I guess I can't let go of boxing yet. Maybe it's my security blanket. It's like always knowing that it's always there, that I can always hit that bag. I get in front of the mirror at my house every day. Just jab and come around and do the moves. It's my connection to boxing. I carry this with me. I sleep with it. I have gloves in my car. I love it. It's me.
好吧，我想我还没能放开拳击。也许它是我的安全毯。这就像总是有那种感觉，它一直都在，我总是可以去打那个沙袋。我每天在家的镜子前。只是刺拳，然后绕过来做动作。这是我和拳击的联系。我带着它。我带着它睡觉。我的车里有拳套。我爱它。这就是我。
That story by Meema Spadola, a documentary filmmaker in New York, who also boxes.
那个故事来自纽约的纪录片导演米玛·斯帕多拉，她本人也打拳。
Round Three, Hard Work. Well, so far on our program we've heard from people who love being the person who throws a punch, unofficial fighters and amateurs. This is a different kind of story. Frankie Cruz Junior boxed in the Olympics twice, won silver and bronze medals. He's a six time Florida State Golden Glove champ, four time National Golden Glove champ. And a year ago he quit amateur fighting, decided he was going to try to make a living from boxing. It's the kind of job where people try to hit and injure you for a living, but you get no health insurance. In a year Frankie's had a broken rib, broken ankle, broken hand, a case of cauliflower ear that's gone untreated. And he's not officially even gone pro yet. He spoke with This American Life producer Julie Snyder.
第三回合，“努力工作”。好吧，到目前为止在我们的节目中，我们已经听到了那些热爱做挥出第一拳的人、非职业选手和业余选手的讲述。这是另一种故事。弗兰基·克鲁兹二世两次参加奥运会拳击比赛，赢得了银牌和铜牌。他是六届佛罗里达州金手套冠军，四届全国金手套冠军。一年前他退出了业余拳击，决定尝试靠拳击谋生。这是一种人们为了谋生而试图击打和伤害你的工作，但你没有医疗保险。在这一年里，弗兰基断了肋骨，断了脚踝，断了手，还得了未治疗的菜花耳。他甚至还没有正式转为职业选手。他接受了《美国生活》制片人朱莉·斯奈德的采访。
Frankie Cruz got his job from one punch. A year ago in a nightclub in Miami, the 170-pound Frankie knocked out a guy weighing 260 with a right hand. He says the punch brought everyone to their feet, including a middle-aged dance club owner from Chicago named Ruben Pazmino.
弗兰基·克鲁兹的一拳为他赢得了这份工作。一年前在迈阿密的一家夜总会，170磅重的弗兰基用一记右手拳击倒了一个260磅的家伙。他说那一拳让所有人起立，包括一位来自芝加哥的、中年夜总会老板鲁本·帕兹米诺。
That night, Ruben had a vision for his Tropicana Club, and it revolved around Frankie Cruz. Later that week, Frankie was on a plane to Chicago.
那天晚上，鲁本对他的Tropicana俱乐部有了一个愿景，而它围绕着弗兰基·克鲁兹。那周晚些时候，弗兰基就坐上了去芝加哥的飞机。
I came in a limousine. They wanted to pick me up in a limousine. They took me to Tropicana. They treat me the nice way. It was fun.
我坐豪华轿车来的。他们想用豪华轿车接我。他们带我去了Tropicana。他们用很好的方式对待我。很有趣。
Let's get ready to rumble!
准备开始轰隆声吧！
It's 2:30 in the morning at the Tropicana, a Latino nightclub that houses four bars, a VIP room, a restaurant, and a huge dance floor with a balcony. It's 2:30 in the morning and nearly a thousand people are packed inside on a Tuesday. After the weightlifting contest and after the lip syncing and after the four erotic dancers finish massaging a shirtless man with baby oil, there's boxing in a regulation ring set up in the middle of the dance floor. It's fight night, and the star is walking in the door. It's Frankie.
凌晨2点半，在Tropicana，一家拉丁夜总会，里面有四个酒吧、一个贵宾室、一家餐厅，还有一个带有阳台的巨大舞池。现在是凌晨2点半，一个周二，里面挤满了近一千人。在举重比赛之后，在口型同步表演之后，在四位情色舞者结束给一个赤裸上身的男人涂抹婴儿油按摩之后，舞池中央设置的正式拳击台里开始了拳击表演。这是拳击之夜，明星正走进来。那是弗兰基。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
[说西班牙语]
Hip and beautiful Latinas turn to look at the 5 foot 10 Nicaraguan born fighter with dyed blond hair and a broken nose. He's not yet dressed in his boxing gear. Instead he wears a mustard-colored sports coat, slacks, and so much jewelry that he literally makes noise when he moves.
美丽火辣的拉丁裔女孩转过身，看着那位5英尺10英寸、尼加拉瓜出生的拳手，他染着金发，鼻梁骨折。他还没换上拳击装备。相反，他穿着芥末色的运动外套、休闲裤，身上戴的首饰多到他走动时会发出声音。
Here's Frankie's job. Here's the job he left his kids and family for. It's free-for-all boxing. Anyone can fight. You can fight. I could fight. Anyone. All you have to do is sign a release form agreeing that if your nose breaks, teeth get punched out, or you end up with a mild concussion, you know it's your fault for being too drunk and easily encouraged by your friends to get into a boxing ring in the first place.
这就是弗兰基的工作。这就是他抛下孩子和家人来做的工作。这是自由拳击。任何人都可以打。你可以打。我也可以打。任何人。你所要做的就是签署一份免责声明，同意如果你的鼻子断了、牙齿被打掉，或者得了轻微脑震荡，你知道这是因为你自己喝得太醉，而且在朋友的怂恿下才走上拳击台的。
You can choose to fight your best friend, your nemesis, or you can take your chances and fight Frankie. If you knock down Frankie, you get $1,000 in cash or the mysterious grand prize. Everyone goes for the cash.
你可以选择和最好的朋友、死对头打架，或者你可以冒险和弗兰基打。如果你击倒了弗兰基，你会得到1000美元现金或者神秘的大奖。每个人都是为了现金来的。
The first guy that did it was wow, he took so much punch. He didn't want to go down. But you know, he finally quit in the second round. And then another one came, bigger. And every time bigger and bigger.
第一个这么做的家伙，哇，他扛了很多拳。他不想倒下。但你知道，他在第二回合最终还是放弃了。然后又来了一个，更大块头的。每一次都越来越大。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] please come to the ring.
[听不清楚的短语]请到拳台来。
Frankie will fight anyone who signs up. Sometimes he's boxed five or six matches in one night, an incredible feat of endurance, something no pro boxer will ever do. And Frankie gets paid the same whether he fights one guy or five guys.
弗兰基会和任何报名的人打。有时他一晚上打五六场，这是一项惊人的耐力壮举，没有职业拳击手会这么做。而且无论弗兰基打一个人还是五个人，他的报酬都是一样的。
He's fought with one arm tied behind his back. He's fought three guys at once. He's fought, in all, 128 fights at the Tropicana. He's won 127.
他曾试过背着一只手打。他曾试过同时打三个人。总共，他在Tropicana打了128场拳。他赢了127场。
Frankie won't say how much he gets paid, but it's not much. And he says he sends most of that money back to his ex-wife, his three children, and his grandmother in Miami. So he's broke all the time.
弗兰基没说他挣多少钱，但没多少。他说他把大部分钱寄回迈阿密给了前妻、三个孩子和祖母。所以他总是身无分文。
For the first seven months he was in Chicago, Frankie lived in a back room of the Tropicana. He also worked as a bouncer on the nights he wasn't boxing. So for days on end, Frankie never left the club. Sometimes on a Saturday or Sunday when the business offices were closed, Frankie would be locked inside and would have to wait for the Tropicana to open in order to leave.
在芝加哥的前七个月里，弗兰基住在Tropicana的一个后室里。他还在他不打拳的晚上做保安。所以一连几天，弗兰基从不离开俱乐部。有时在周六或周日办公室关门时，弗兰基会被锁在里面，不得不等Tropicana开门才能离开。
He says he didn't mind it that much until Ruben, the owner, took his television set away in order to start up a new karaoke night.
他说他并不怎么介意，直到老板鲁本为了开始一个新的卡拉OK之夜拿走了他的电视机。
I finished fighting sometimes four or five guys in the night. I used to go outside and cry and say, why I'm doing this? I think I'm not getting paid enough to do it. Everything is business. And if you don't talk business good, you don't study the business good, you will never make it.
我有时晚上打完四五个人。我过去常到外面哭，说，我为什么要做这个？我想我没赚到足够的钱。一切都是生意。如果你不把生意谈好，如果你不好好研究生意，你永远不会成功。
OK, uno, dos, tres, por favor!
OK，一、二、三，拜托！
Right now two African American guys from the audience have signed up to fight each other and are going at it in the ring. Both weigh well over 200 pounds. While they clumsily stumble around the ring, taking wide punches and falling against the ropes, the almost preteen-looking ring girls get instructions on what they're supposed to do when Frankie re-enters the ring.
现在，观众席上的两名非裔美国人报了名要互相搏斗，正在拳台上激战。两人体重都远超200磅。当他们笨拙地在拳台上踉跄，打出大范围的拳头并撞向围绳时，那些看起来未成年的拳台女孩得到了指示，当弗兰基重新进入拳台时她们该做什么。
Walk around that way real sexy and then stop in front of the camera so he can take a picture of it. You take your robe off when you get inside the ring. And then you put your robe on before you get back out.
走那边性感点，然后在摄像头前停下来，让他拍照。你进入拳台时把长袍脱掉。然后在出去前把长袍穿上。
The girls in thong bikinis hustle around as Frankie emerges, now wearing a blue and gold running suit, a straw cowboy hat, and a Nicaraguan scarf tied around his neck.
女孩们穿着丁字比基尼走来走去，弗兰基出现了，现在穿着蓝色和金色的运动服，头戴草帽，脖子上系着尼加拉瓜围巾。
Frankie stands with the announcer while the two ring girls walk in circles, each holding an end of his championship belt. The belt always gets the center spotlight.
弗兰基站在播音员身边，而两个拳台女孩绕圈走动，每人拿着冠军腰带的一端。腰带总是处于中心聚光灯下。
When training, Frankie lays the belt down next to his treadmill, says a prayer, and starts running. It's on the floor next to him when he's jumping rope.
训练时，弗兰基把腰带放在跑步机旁边，做个祈祷，然后开始跑。当他跳绳时，腰带就在旁边的地板上。
Once when I showed up to interview him at his gym, before we could go off to talk, he opened his gym bag and pulled out a little plastic stand that you use for picture frames. He put the stand on a desk facing the front door of the gym and put the belt on it.
有一次我在他的健身房采访他，在我们离开去谈话之前，他打开健身房包，拿出一个通常用于相框的小塑料支架。他把支架放在面对健身房前门的桌子上，把腰带放了上去。
On one end of the belt is Frankie's name. On the other, Viva Auto Sales Park because unfortunately, the Tropicana didn't give him the belt. For several months Frankie says, he continually asked Ruben for one but kept getting blown off.
腰带的一端是弗兰基的名字。另一端是“万岁汽车销售园”，因为不幸的是，Tropicana没给他那条腰带。弗兰基说有好几个月，他不断向鲁本要，但一直被敷衍。
I just thought at least to get a boxer of the year in the club. And I've been talking about him. Do some thing special, you know? When I wanted to get the belt for him I want him to present it, give it to me. But he never gone there and told me here, Frankie. Here, go have fun. It's not fair.
我只是想至少在俱乐部里当个年度拳击手。我一直在谈论他。做点特别的事，你知道吗？当我想让他为我拿到腰带时，我想要他亲手颁发给我。但他从没去过那里对我说，“给你，弗兰基。拿着去玩吧。”这不公平。
Instead, a friend introduced Frankie to the owner of Viva Auto Sales. The guy agreed to buy the belt for Frankie if he could put the Viva name on it. It's a good investment. You meet Frankie, you meet the belt.
相反，一个朋友把弗兰基介绍给了“万岁汽车销售”的老板。那个家伙同意为弗兰基买下这条腰带，前提是他能在上面印上万岁的名字。这笔投资不错。你遇见弗兰基，你就遇见了腰带。
Leaving the belt with the ring girls, Frankie climbs between the ropes and gets in his corner. His managers, Danny and Hank, are there with him. They're grooming him to go pro in June. They give him a place to live. They see that he eats right, doesn't drink, and trains every day.
把腰带留给拳台女孩后，弗兰基爬进围绳，进入角落。他的经理丹尼和汉克都在那里。他们正在培养他六月份转职业。他们为他提供住处。他们确保他吃得健康、不喝酒，并且每天训练。
Frankie's opponent doesn't look too intimidating. Staggering, he enters the ring wearing jeans, a long sleeve green shirt, and Doc Martens. He's at least 240 pounds, complete with overhanging gut and love handles. It would take a lot of alcohol to make someone like this believe he belongs in a ring with a trained Olympic medalist. But he's had a lot of alcohol.
弗兰基的对手看起来并不太吓人。他踉跄着进入拳台，穿着牛仔裤，绿色的长袖衬衫，还有马汀靴。他至少有240磅，有着下垂的肚腩和爱的把手。得喝多少酒才能让这样的人相信他属于一个训练有素的奥运奖牌获得者的拳台。但他确实喝了不少酒。
Hank and Danny size up the guy. The fact that he's drunk means his fighting may be sloppy. But it also makes it harder on Frankie because the drunks don't feel the pain as much. As the bell goes off, Hank screams instructions from the corner.
汉克和丹尼评估那个家伙。他喝醉了意味着他的打法可能会很烂。但这也会让弗兰基更难打，因为醉汉感觉不到太多疼痛。当铃声响起，汉克在角落里尖叫指示。
Get out of there. Get out of there. Come on.
滚出来。滚出来。加油。
Frankie's splayed against the ropes. In a shocking move, Frankie's opponent came racing out of the corner and immediately began swinging. It's a barfighter's tactic, get in the first punch. He gets Frankie up against the ropes in the corner and on the defense, as Frankie only manages to get in a few body jabs.
弗兰基撞向围绳。在令人震惊的一招中，弗兰基的对手冲出角落，立即开始挥拳。那是街头打架者的策略，先打出第一拳。他把弗兰基逼到角落的围绳边，转入防御，弗兰基只能勉强打出几记腹部刺拳。
Punch him. Frankie, punch him. There you go! Don't let him push you around.
打他。弗兰基，打他。就是这样！别让他推着你走。
It never occurred to me how hard Frankie would have to work to win his fights, how much of a beating he takes. He looks tired and confused.
我从未想过弗兰基必须多么努力才能赢得他的比赛，他被打得有多惨。他看起来疲惫又困惑。
I want him on the floor. On the floor. On the floor.
我要他倒在地板上。在地板上。在地板上。
At the end of the first round, Hank and Danny counsel Frankie in the corner. Mostly it's a big pep talk. You're the champ, they yell. You're the champ.
第一回合结束时，汉克和丹尼在角落里给弗兰基指导。大多是大声的鼓励。你是冠军，他们大喊。你是冠军。
Frankie, hey! Show me some intensity. You know what to do. Kick his ass.
弗兰基，嘿！给我看看强度。你知道该怎么做。踢他的屁股。
In round two, Frankie comes back. His opponent's punches becomes weaker. At times they miss Frankie completely. And almost gently, Frankie edges the guy up against the ropes in his own corner and does combinations to his head, pounds away at him. Blood spurts everywhere.
第二回合，弗兰基回来了。对手的拳头变得更弱。有时他们完全打不到弗兰基。弗兰基近乎温和地把那个家伙逼向他自己角落的围绳边，打出一套组合拳对着他的头，猛烈抨击他。鲜血喷溅得到处都是。
It's an incredible moment, satisfying in a way I never would have guessed. Sweat and spit fly off Frankie's body. Hank and Danny go wild. The crowd goes wild. Frankie breaks the guy's nose and the ref ends the fight.
这是一个令人难以置信的时刻，以一种我从未预料到的方式令人满足。汗水和唾沫从弗兰基身上飞出。汉克和丹尼疯狂了。人群疯狂了。弗兰基打断了那个家伙的鼻梁，裁判终止了比赛。
When Frankie staggers back and drops his hands, blood drips from his gloves onto the starched, white mat. Hank screams at him.
当弗兰基踉跄后退并放下手时，血从他的拳套上滴落在浆过的白色拳台上。汉克对他尖叫。
Hey, that's the beating I like to see. That's the way you throw the punches.
嘿，那是我喜欢看到的痛打。那就是你挥拳的方式。
Boxing can make you feel so small. The force of the punches is so brutal and penetrating that it's almost mythical. When Frankie climbed out of the ring, he asked me if I was impressed. I couldn't even answer. I couldn't talk to him.
拳击会让你感觉自己非常渺小。拳头的力量是如此残酷和具有穿透力，以至于近乎神话。当弗兰基爬下拳台时，他问我是否留下了深刻印象。我甚至无法回答。我无法和他说话。
In only a few minutes, this guy who has to beg for a belt from a used car dealership suddenly seemed untouchable.
在短短几分钟内，这个必须向二手车行乞求腰带的家伙突然看起来不可触及。
I've asked Frankie over and over what he loves about boxing, and he doesn't really say anything. He doesn't like hurting people. He doesn't have any romantic ideas about the tradition of boxing or its primal appeal. That's not why he boxes. It's a job. A job that doesn't pay all that much in grimy, punishing, working conditions. A job that he's good at, but that doesn't hold a lot of mystery anymore. The one thing that makes it special for Frankie is the crowds.
我反复问弗兰基他热爱拳击的什么，他真的没说什么。他不喜欢伤害人。他没有任何关于拳击传统或其原始吸引力的浪漫想法。这不是他打拳的原因。这是一份工作。一份在肮脏、惩罚性的工作环境中赚不到多少钱的工作。一份他擅长，但不再有什么神秘感的工作。弗兰基唯一感到特别的事情是人群。
What I love about boxing is the people. I think if people don't go see you, it won't be fun. I believe the people, even if they're not cheering for me, or they're booing for me-- but after I win or after I finish the fight, I know I got all those people who didn't cheer for me, they're going to give me their hands and they're going to say, wow, you had a great fight.
我热爱拳击的是人们。我想如果没人来看你，那会很无聊。我相信人们，即使他们不是在为我欢呼，或者是在为我喝倒彩——但在我赢了之后或者在比赛结束之后，我知道所有那些没为我欢呼的人，他们会给我握手，他们会说，哇，你打了一场精彩的比赛。
After his match, Frankie begins jumping around, running through the crowds up to the top floor of the nightclub, looking for fans. He does this every time, Hank says. When Frankie sees me, he stops and motions for me to follow, so I can record how much the crowd loves him.
比赛结束后，弗兰基开始跳来跳去，冲向人群跑到夜总会的顶层，寻找粉丝。汉克说，他每次都这么做。当弗兰基看到我时，他停下并示意我跟上，这样我就可以记录下人们有多爱他。
Frankie.
弗兰基。
Yeah, baby.
是的，宝贝。
Congratulations, brother. You're getting bigger and bigger, baby.
恭喜，兄弟。你越来越大了，宝贝。
I'm getting better and better too.
我也越来越好了。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交谈声]
That's right. You knocked that guy pretty good, esse.
没错。你把那个家伙打得不错，伙计。
Out of the ring looking for attention, Frankie doesn't seem like a giant anymore. He's a guy, boyish even.
走出拳台寻找关注时，弗兰基看起来不再是个巨人了。他只是个普通人，甚至有点孩子气。
A lot of people come over and shake his hand, say a word. A lot more push right by him, heading down to the ring where six women from the audience are now taking part in a do-it-yourself strip tease. Men in the audience pull dollar bills from their wallets and shove past. They don't look at Frankie.
很多人过来和他握手，说一句话。更多人直接推开他，冲向拳台，那里六名观众中的女性现在正在参加DIY脱衣舞表演。观众中的男人从钱包里掏出钞票挤过去。他们不看弗兰基。
[MEN CHANT "TAKE IT OFF"]
[男人们高呼“脱掉它”]
Oh, it's Lisa's birthday today, y'all. Say happy birthday to Lisa.
噢，今天是丽莎的生日，各位。祝丽莎生日快乐。
That story from This American Life producer Julie Snyder.
那个故事来自《美国生活》制片人朱莉·斯奈德。
We thought we'd close out our program today with this recording. It's Muhammad Ali, then Cassius Clay, recorded in 1964.
我们想以这段录音结束今天的节目。这是穆罕默德·阿里，当时叫卡修斯·克莱，录制于1964年。
[MUSIC- "STAND BY ME" BY CASSIUS CLAY]
[音乐- 卡修斯·克莱演唱的“Stand By Me”]
Well, our program was produced today by Julie Snyder and myself with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Senior editor Paul Tough. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Rachel Day, Laura Doggett and [? Sahini ?] Davenport.
嗯，我们的节目今天由朱莉·斯奈德和我制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔和南希·厄普代克参与。高级编辑保罗·塔夫。贡献编辑杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林和顾问莎拉·沃威尔。制作帮助来自瑞秋·戴、劳拉·多格特和[？萨希尼？]达文波特。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
If you want to buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago, 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. Our email address [email protected] .
如果您想购买本节目的磁带，请致电芝加哥的WBEZ，312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected]。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who every single day calls me into his office, points to a picture of Garrison Keillor and says--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他每天都叫我进办公室，指着一张加里森·凯勒的照片说——
Let's get him.
搞定他。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。